and what famous motion offense
reasonable I've never been offended in
my life I've maybe been angered up in
enraged up in the sight attraction I've
never been offended this FP be marching
people who want us to stay shackled to
the EU or you look at the truth people
who are offended by here and the
waving vagina and hatted people this is
a profession in being offended we saw
that in on the Trump marches so in the
anti-breakage marches it's all list of
profession it's almost the sort of
middle class oh I must go out there and
demonstrate but I've got my designer
with me well well you just think you see
that those specific money industry if
this currency involved in being offended
at them if you're in a European
Parliament yeah there are laws now
against hate crime this boys here about
Tony Blair what was the first thing that
he and his wife did because she's a
human rights lawyer and the human rights
industry is now become an industry the
race relations industry has become an
industry the offended those that want
are professionally being offended there
is money behind all this and and also
loss of protein it's very very dangerous
for our freedoms and freedom of speech
the rest of them lightly smarter and VA
be any people I follow up winding you to
wave to the top you know it's like oh my
god I'm not right I'm up first and it's
a dangerous message to send out to young
university students that but if you're
not wait then your life is essentially
good message for universities to piss in
tonight's debate but debate is being
closed down I was invited Cambridge and
I turned it down just a bit debating
amongst ourselves I do I prefer to
debate the wider people but I bet now if
they were to so many and information
those had to be an invitation that there
would be a demonstration outside because
I'm so good at they can't be there no
platforming and we have to question why
why are we funding these kids to go to
these universities to be offended to be
professionally offended and race again
is the the race I think is particularly
pernicious the LBGT IQ is particularly
pernicious you know basically we're all
equal
nobody is more equal than others women
true agenda the next thing will be the
LGBT people you should get their own
merit not because the color of your skin
or your sexual orientation of course and
also you know listen when you buy a book
for instance issue properly and the
Koran is nothing more than people and
then blue held together by glue some
people are being
taken to the course on Facebook people
are burning the Koran soon let's do it
properly
you can do it up what they want because
what is hate crime and it is an
interpretation are you offended so if
somebody rings on the police and says
they're offended then that is a crime
it's not a crime even this week I read
that it's a guy who's a sort of
born-again Christian preacher who's
reading from the Bible accent Paul's
Cathedral and the bishop has banned him
from basically eulogizing outsider where
we going with all this this is what
we're gonna stand up for if I'm offended
by something and I choose to rip it up I
chose to Republic Cameron's letter over
peace that he got saying that we should
stay in the European Union because they
listen everything had changed from
Merkel I stood there according to the
FPV people the EU that would be a
actually would be an offense if somebody
was offended by that and that's where
this is going is very very dangerous to
move either up completing the border
police and there's a Karl Marx office
across in my building and listen people
are you offended NASA team muscle me I
don't want to live in a world where
someone's arrested because I'm offended
is just simply wrong to become sports
out there and of children's in a
journalist that was flying down trying
to interview that he had a big camera on
the back of his shoulder there was a
plate glass window one side I had he
also on it's very sleepy and when I
races in the pond
and violence etc but I feel violated
tongue-in-cheek but it was actually a
dangerous situation because this guy's
known and I said a drunken German chased
me down the corridor because he thought
he was entitled to interview it well
nobody's entitled to interview me unless
I want to give an interview and that was
a very dangerous situation I was also
told that I was a stupid
I think woman by very senior labour MEP
but that was okay because I come from
the right on politics and my flying
offense and the attacks on me don't
matter and I'm not going to make a
formal complaint about it because by me
and I don't take offense but when I
stood up in the chamber and I said this
all the voices silenced and mrs. Norbury
knew the high priest at Central High
Representative High Priestess I called
at the gender quota woman who is
supposed to be the so-called foreign
secretary who was taking part in this
debate as a female but she's gender
quota so I take no notice of her when I
stood up I said this is MA bringing you
look at me when I'm speaking the red
chamber as she did she just sat down
there was no comment on the offense
have been committed against me